one of the things i've discussed with
you guys um
a bunch over the last four years and
really over the last two months in
particular
uh are a lot of these right wingers are
a lost cause and they voted for trump
once or twice
whatever you know they may never
understand the error of their ways
but that it's important for us to
remember that there were lots of
supposed left wingers who back in 2016
maybe stayed home because they didn't
think it was important enough
uh the difference between trump and
hillary and they said ah i'm gonna stay
home if it's these two i'm
kind of kind of opting out some leftists
said
i almost would rather it be trump if
it's not going to be
my preferred candidate because hillary
is just a centrist shill and they would
be the same
and of course we found out that that's
very much not the case we have seen
donald trump do things that i never
imagined any president would do never
mind hillary clinton
um i have not been calling for apologies
but i have been saying it would be
important to recognize how
wrong those leftists were i did get a
call from someone this morning saying
uh i regret not voting for hillary in
2016. it was wrong of me
not to do that take a listen hey dave
i'm holding my baby so if you hear a
little
talk that might be him but just want to
call you and say with watching the show
on the 11th
and i am one of the people who did not
vote for hillary in 2016.
right i voted for jill and i regret that
since then i voted for joe this election
cycle because of people like you and
destiny who taught me about harm
reduction
wow and i'm eternally grateful for that
so thank you for teaching me about harm
reduction buddy that was
really really good for my life and
really probably good for the country
thanks anyway dave so that's a beautiful
voicemail
and it's great to hear things like that
and we also need to recognize that
in order to really get more change we
have to deprogram
some of the 75 million trumpists that
sure
you know we learned something like what
was it eight percent of bernie
supporters ended up voting for trump
instead of hillary in 2016.
these are relatively small numbers they
could have made a difference by the way
because it was so close in 2016
but we really need to attack the issue
of the 75 million people who thought
voting for trump after four years of
disaster was was a good idea
or at least a better idea than voting
for joe biden on today's bonus show
congresswoman liz chaney facing major
blowback after
embracing the impeachment of donald
trump in the house we will talk about
the metal detector guns on the house
floor fiasco that is plaguing the house
of representatives
and ex-michigan governor snyder
has been criminally charged rick snyder
criminally charged in the flint water
crisis
we will talk about the charges he's up
against the possible penalty and what we
expect
flint still has a water problem
understand how long it's been flint
still has a water problem
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at joinpakman.com
it's quick it's easy you can use the
coupon code better21 to get yourself a
discount or
make a pledge at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow that will also give you
access to the bonus show
in either case i will see you then or
otherwise
tomorrow reminder we are off monday for
the martin luther king day holiday
off monday but with you today for the
bonus show and tomorrow as well